Звільнений Ізюм нагадує місто-привид.
На вулицях майже не лишилося неушкоджених будівель.
Але біля відділку поліції від самого ранку людно. Це люди, які шукають померлих чи зниклих безвісти родичів.
Серед них і Людмила.
Шукаю свого рідного сина, який зник безвісти. Тіла не знайшли, тіла немає.
Жінка сподівається хоч щось дізнатися про свого старшого сина Едуарда.
Він - досвідчений військовий, з початку повномасштабного вторгнення служив у теробороні Ізюма.
Зв'язок із хлопцем зник ще в березні. В умовах окупації жінка не наважувалася розпитувати про долю сина.
Я переховувалася, у мене старший син був "атовець", три контракти у нього було,
і я дуже боялася, що на мене хтось там наведе…
Бо в мене дуже багато військових речей у квартирі, всього дуже багато, я дуже боялася.
Два тижні тому Людмила дізналася, що у березні був авіаналіт на будинок,
де разом із теробороною перебував її син. Військові розповіли, що його завалило уламками.
Жінка досі не втрачає надії, що син міг вижити.
Думаємо, що тоді, може, і росіяни заходили, може, взяли в полон.
Є надія ще, невелика, але є.
Після звільнення на околицях Ізюма знайшли ось це масове поховання.
На могилах - хрести з номерами. Тут виявили 450 тіл,
ідентифікувати за зовнішніми ознаками більшість із них уже неможливо.
Відомо лише, що тут поховані і цивільні, і військові.
Деякі - із зав'язаними за спиною руками.
Тепер знайти могили своїх рідних і підтвердити, що там справді поховані вони,
люди можуть лише за результатами ДНК-аналізів.
Ми вже мали ситуації, коли в могилі повинна була бути жінка, а там був чоловік,
в могилі повинна була бути одна людина, а в цій могилі було поховано дві-три людини.
І ми зараз для того, аби встановити родичів, аби встановити особи загиблих людей,
ініціювали активно процес дачі ДНК-матеріалів від родичів, аби ми вже мали юридичні факти
і мали в кримінальних провадженнях чітку інформацію щодо осіб, які загинули, або яких було вбито.
Спершу з людьми спілкуються слідчі і прокурори - збирають анкетні дані,
усю інформацію про загиблих чи зниклих безвісти. Це тривалий і кропіткий процес.
У цій білій машині - мобільна лабораторія, де збирають ДНК-матеріал.
Юлія привела маленьку доньку, аби експерти взяли її зразок.
Жінка сподівається, що так вдасться забрати тіло чоловіка, який помер після мікроінсульту.
Він 20 березня помер. Його спочатку в дворі поховали, а потім росіяни перепоховали під номерами,
а тепер, як прийшла Україна, забрали на експертизу в Харків.
Результатів треба буде чекати декілька місяців, адже через завантаженість лабораторій,
матеріал відправляють на аналіз в інші області.
Анна принесла на аналіз ДНК гребінці двох літніх жінок, за якими доглядала.
Хоче поховати їх по-людськи.
Якраз прильоти були, ми на кладовищі не були, їх ховали без нас.
Усе, що треба, скупили. Ховали їх без нас. Не можна було на той момент приїхати.
Надія Іванова прийшла здати свій ДНК-матеріал, щоб знайти батька.
Коли в Ізюм заїжджали російські танки, вона виїхала з міста разом з дитиною.
А батько, у якого на тлі бомбардувань міста стався інсульт, залишився в лікарні.
Невдовзі шпиталь розбомбили. Надія спершу сподівалася, що батько вижив.
Нині вже знає, що їй треба шукати тіло, аби поховати його.
Я знайшла лікаря, який виїхав з Ізюма. Він мені сказав, що він загинув там.
Його неможливо було вивезти.
Він сказав, що там залишалися у підвалах ті, кого вони змогли спустити, ті, хто спускався.
Батько був лежачий. Він був з інсультом, він тільки дихав. Він казав, що його спустити неможливо було.
Тим часом Людмила дізнається більше деталей про долю свого зниклого безвісти сина.
Жінка зустрічається з побратимами Едуарда, які були разом із ним під час обстрілу.
Бійці не дають Людмилі сподіватися на краще - вони певні, що її син загинув під завалами,
евакуювати його під обстрілами не змогли.
Але припускають, що тіло хлопця могли забрати росіяни, які саме зайшли в місто.
Ось машина стояла його - вони витягли машину, хоч це вже була не машина, а шматок металобрухту був.
Машину витягли. Вони в будь-якому разі його дістали.
На жаль, за такого авіаудару, і враховуючи, де перебував цей хлопець, у мить коли вибухала авіабомба,
вижити в нього шансів не було. Ми особисто пересвідчилися - він був мертвий.
У Людмили залишився молодший син. Йому всього 19, але він так само воював на Харківщині, у боях втратив ногу.
Нині хлопець на реабілітації.
Я дуже вдячна, що в мене менший син живий ще. І дуже сподіваюся знайти старшого.
Людмила ще буде спілкуватися зі слідчими. Покази даватимуть і побратими її зниклого сина.
Поки це єдине, чим вони можуть допомогти жінці.